[Music]
we're talking about House of Lies your
character you dance you get to you get
to dance some in this in this in a
recent episode not every episode yeah I
had a scary dancing scene where it was
written and then she dances very sexily
and seduces him and I thought what and
it's cuz that's very nerve-wracking I
don't do sexy very well I've been doing
cute to the end of the day but I can't
sexy if that's not my thing
but also it's funny because women they
have a choice it's it they can dance
sexy or they can sort of be a little
goofy about it which in its own way I
think is sexy you know or well thought
out because I've got some dance moves
that I didn't show on house of lives
that I usually bring out on the dance
floor that are prime alright well now I
think the follow-up question is let's
see him
[Applause]
that's not a question it's not a
question characters that you can take
out at like a wedding or any sort of
characters when you dance yeah like what
kind of characters what are we talking
about well like you do the stewardess
and there's like a series of moves I
don't know if I can get a beat from
anybody gonna be like you can be like
mask mask seat belt seat belt I love
that that's great
that's a good way
can I have another one please you can
I'll be good this is a good one so this
one's kind of you if you make eye
contact or someone from your cross like
I walked in the room and you're like I
got it if you give me another beat this
is called the Baker peep this
[Music]
[Applause]
I love the bacon
and then I could come over and be like
she was totally vibing me she came in
and she was like that's old drywall
Junction his new dance the diabetic
please terrible disease anyway what big
miracle this is the movie and this is
based on a real a film based on a true
story 1988 whales trapped in the Alaskan
ice and the whole world sort of came
together to try and help them yeah it's
a really cool story it's very very
inspiring yeah we had mr. Kosinski in
the film as well it's got great cakes he
does okay whatever you know I can say
that cuz I know his wife he does he has
a very good cake okay I don't want to
hear about that it bums me out to hear
about other people's great cakes
[Applause]
the the fact it is a very heartwarming
story did you learn a lot about whales
like real things about whales uh yeah
not well we worked with animatronic
whales but I did but I learned a lot
about them oh they're not real no
they're real and I learned that day rape
whales rape animatronic whales great
sonic well guys real whales so I said
animatronic I thought you meant they've
been programmed to do that ok no we're
not real yeah well um I mean when I
Wikipedia it they I didn't Wikipedia
well rape I just want to see your search
history I bet it will rate will rate
will work well rate it takes like three
male whales to secure and corner a
female until she decides to let the
mating begin and gives in I'm sorry in
my book that is rape so that's a
heartwarming tale about whales
we need to save those whales for the
work and continuing
get trapped in the ice they're not
getting any action